hi the
next section i'd like to talk about uh
will be done in two segments if not more
because i want to go into some detail
about my
my own teacher and um
i'm getting lots of comments on facebook
actually more than
on youtube about uh
what i'm saying and
people are thinking that i'm knocking
the aikikin
versus iwamaikido and yes i know it's
coming across like that
but as you'll see over the course of
time
i'm hoping that it will come out as a
more balanced
view and an overall view
we all have opinions and um we're not in
school anymore well i'm not
and i don't need to please anybody
or climb any mountains or
have any award awards given to me
because i'm a good
person saying the right things to the
right people
so i'm i as i've said before i just want
to say
as as it is about how i see it
i started in 1973 and
saito sensei started writing some books
in 1973.
to me he was the only outgoing japanese
teacher at the time
who wanted to share his knowledge with
the world
and those senses i could over the world
you can read about this but if you
haven't
already he made the first three books
and he was asked by the hong ko dojo in
tokyo
if he would stop writing them
this is what he said whether it's true
or not
i don't know i'm just telling you what i
was told
he was asked to stop writing the books
because
the world perhaps wasn't ready
so he stopped but then again in 1975 if
i remember correctly
he made number two
he also made a cine film
and it to me it was the only set
of film that was released to the world
that showed the weapons and you could
copy it you know you could play the
films like i did
cop go in my garden copy them come back
in look at the films
copy them and i enjoyed watching his
weapons
i didn't actually enjoy him as a teacher
because he looked a bit of a monster
a bit of a bulldog really
very powerful very dynamic but not what
i
thought aikido should be because
my training was more about flowing
it was hard training very physical in
those days more like
fighting each other than flowing with
each other
but i had the money and i bought all
these books
and the films
this uh did not make me want to follow
him as a teacher
but i wanted to follow the techniques
ten years after training and being
disappointed with my own
teachers i wrote to stan crowning i
don't have the letter to prove it
but i wrote to stan
in and said to him i'm looking for
a teacher that i can
rely on that it will be the true aikido
and i stated the name of a teacher that
i really liked
he suggested that i didn't look to that
teacher
but i looked toward to cite her scentsy
because in his words
he said this is the only teacher that i
know who's
teaching o senses aikido
though since he taught anyone
looking back over the years
i went to new zealand in 1983
and met psychosensity as i've said
before
at that point he'd just retired from the
far
sorry the railway
and he was going to be invited to start
teaching
seminars and he had the time to do so
on that seminar there was i believe
62 or 63 students
he was so delighted he said it was a
really big seminar for him
many many years later i was on the
seminar with him in paris
and there were 700 students on the map
he was always a giving person he wanted
to give a lot
he would make the students in paris
build
a platform of mats so that he could
stand
on top of them so that everybody could
see
he wanted everybody to get to know
his aikido
he wanted to show everybody clearly so
he made half the people go and sit in
the stands
until he taught the first half and then
he took the second
so when he was
in new zealand i first met him
he was a very normal person
without any you know thought of
him being a great master he was just an
ikidoka from iwama
yes he was the caretaker he run the dojo
and was the head of it but as a person
it was as if i was just meeting an
everyday
village person with nothing special
about him whatsoever but his heart was
phenomenal
smooth powerful
always friendly smiling
but when on the mat or in class
he was so severe and strict he would
shout at you
and we would grind you to feeling that
you're
worse than the dirt on the ground below
you
many times i've come off the mat almost
in tears where he shattered
me through shouting saying that i was
getting it wrong
but isn't that the way the old masters a
true master
break the student rebuild the student
build the person forge them into a new
character
make them see that they must be humble
make them see that they must be strong
to me these are the traits of us of a
fine master
as the years went by more and more
people invited him around the world
more and more people saw him not
everybody liked him
because he was very critical he used to
criticize
the aikikai and say how they've
destroyed our senses aikido
the problem is when you're his student
and that close to him
you also get a feminist tongue
and you start shouting at people and you
start going around
on seminars and when you see other stars
that are weaker than yours in your
opinion
you criticize them you shout at them you
put them down
sadly this was not me
but it was me it was the jackal and the
hide
and i'd like to talk more about this in
the next section
because i followed
the art and i also found a man
but once he passed away from this earth
i became myself and that's why i'm
talking you to you today
to give you an opinion of what
i believe and felt
about iwan like you know inside of cincy
thank you please leave comments or
anything more that you'd like to know
below
and i will try to fulfill your requests
and answer them